Mind your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
Suppose ax + by = 5, ax^2 + by^2 = 10,
ax^3 + by^3 = 50,
and ax^4 +  by^4 =130.
What is the value of 13(x+ y - xy) - 120(a+b)?
This problem is adapted from the Mathematics Olympiad of Nepal.
Pause if you'd like to give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
Now rather than
individually solving for x, y, a, and b,
We'll solve for the quantity x+y, the quantity xy, and the quantity a+b.
These will be easier to solve for, and we'll still have the required information to evaluate the original problem.
Seeing this kind of trick only comes from practice, and from solving many math videos per month.
So, let's get started. We'll start with the 2nd-degree equation.
We'll multiply both sides by the quantity x+y.
We'll then distribute the left-hand side.
We're going to get another equation.
We can now simplify this equation.
Notice, we have ax^3 + by^3, and that's equal to 50.
We substitute that for the remaining two terms.
We factor out xy, and we're left with a factor of ax + by.
But this is interesting, because we know that's equal to 5, so we'll substitute that in.
We'll now take this entire equation, and put it to the side.
We'll do the same sort of process on the cubic equation.
We'll multiply both sides by the quantity x+y, and then we'll distribute the left-hand side.
We're going to get another equation, which will have many simplifications here.
Here, ax^4 + by^4 =  130.
Then, we factor out xy, and we're left with a factor x^2 + by^2.
This is equal to 10, which we'll substitute.
We now consider these two equations.
We'll multiply this second equation by 2, so that the factor on xy is equal to 10.
We now subtract the second equation, and we'll eliminate the entire xy factor from both equations.
We get 30 = 30(x+y)
We can then solve that x + y is equal to 1.
We substitute that back into the first equation, and we can solve that xy = -8.
We're making good progress, and now we'll consider the linear equation. We'll multiply both sides by the quantity x+y.
We'll then distribute on the left-hand side(again?), and we're going to end up with an equation, which we'll simplify.
Here, ax^2 + by^2 = 10.
Then we factor with xy, and we're left with a factor of a+b.
This equation, we can use the information we've already derived.
Here, xy = -8, and x+y = 1.
We substitute those in, and that'll allow us to solve for a+b.
And we'll get a+b = 5/8.
From these three pieces of information,
we can evaluate our original problem.
We substitute in, and then we simplify, and we get the result of 42.
It's amazing how often 42 is the answer to many things in life and in the universe.
Thanks for making Mind your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always, thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.